dating app technology puts the power to
meet people in the palm of your hand you
swipe right if you're interested in
swipe left if you're not now that same
idea is helping to pair dogs in
desperate need of a home with potential
owners Don de leurs at a rescue center
in Madison New Jersey that's filled with
animals waiting for the perfect match
Don good morning good morning I hate my
job on pace like this the the dogs and
cats at places like Saint Hubert's
animal welfare center are among the
millions waiting for adoption but now
there's some really creative new social
media apps that helps making them get
known to people who want new animals
much easier it's picture day at New
York's Animal Haven where Joey jewel and
hold it are posing for adoption
portraits the challenges for us is
trying to help as many animals as we can
Tiffany Lacey is the rescues executive
director how much has social media
helped what you do I can't even begin to
tell you how big of a difference the
world of animal welfare as soon as we
post an animal people are coming to the
shelter to meet the animal it's really
turned the whole thing on its head
pictures of these pups will join the
more than 125,000 posted nationwide on
apps like bark buddy it behaves just
like tinder except instead of finding a
date you're finding a dog that can be
your best friend Stacy Grissom runs the
content team at bark a disruptor in the
pet toy and treat industry and best
known for its bark box monthly
subscription service and you get to work
with your dogs we do get to work with
our dykes that's one of the bigger perks
how did the dogs get on bark buddy and
how do people find them there are
thousands of shelters across the country
that are uploading their dogs to pet
finder and we are able to pull all of
that information and just present it in
a different way that's fun and engaging
and not what you would expect like
popular dating apps dog lovers swipe
right to like and left to pass but who
would swipe left on
that's the problem I have you know if I
go on there it's like it swipe right
swipe right it's right by location
settings make it easy to meet dogs in
your area and you can specify
characteristics like size age and gender
so you want to get down at their level
but since appearance may matter most get
something squeaky Grissom and her dog
Pam offered some tips on how to take
better pictures and then if all else
fails you just put a little bit of
peanut butter right on their nose
we found Jax's photo it was like we need
to meet this dog you knew it from the
photo absolutely he had his ears
flapping
his tongue was lolling he looks like a
complete dingus and it was you have like
love at first sight Rebecca and Mitchell
thuria turned to bark buddy after their
dog slash lost his best friend their cat
Brutus and once we had to put Brutus
down slash was very obviously distraught
you noticed he was lonely and there was
a really big hole in the house do you
believe in love at first sight like on
these apps where you just see a photo of
an animal and that's it yes I do I do
and that's the beginning I believe in
that but it is the beginning process
just like in a human dating app you've
got to get to know him well the fairy is
that meant getting Slash's approval to
immediately him and slash her we're
getting along great and he was super
friendly from the get-go so this was a
success happily ever after
absolutely yes they helped us finish our
family I can't imagine life without him
no bark buddy is free to use and they
don't have ads but right now it's just
for dogs however there are plenty of
cats like rum here also looking for a
new home
dawn what a great idea I know thank you
so much for that story and I'm learning
that a ding it's is a good thing it
looks like a dingus that's a good thing
look for a dog that looks like a dingus
a complete dingus